[Musik]
schönen guten abend zu einer knackig
kurzen halbzeit ausgabe der heute ja
nicht nur sportlich auch politisch heute
ein spannendes aufeinandertreffen zweier
nationen außenministerin berbalk sprach
heute mit ihrem russischen amtskollegen
lawrow über die ukraine krise sie die
novizen auf diplomatischen parkett er
seit über 17 jahren russlands
außenminister über die bewährungsprobe
die viel länger dauerte als geplant und
wie es ausging axel sturm gut eineinhalb
stunden verspätet öffnen sich die türen
im gästehaus des außenministeriums
pressekonferenz die neue deutsche
außenministerin hatte für das gespräch
mit ihrem russischen kollegen sergej
lavrov eine wie sie sagt dicke themen
mappe mitgebracht vieles das verbinde
aber auch eine klare haltung zum
russischen truppenaufmarsch an der
grenze zur ukraine
in den letzten wochen haben sich mehr
als hundert tausend russische soldaten
mit panzern und geschützen der nähe der
ukraine versammelt ohne
nachvollziehbaren grund und es ist
schwer das nicht als drohung zu
verstehen
wir haben erklärt dass es keine
eskalation gibt es von der westliche
politiker derzeit sprechen gemeint ist
die präsenz unserer eigenen truppen auf
dem eigenen territorium und die
durchführung notwendiger
gefechtsausbildung
die deutsche spitzendiplomat in cham
geschichts und selbstbewusst und
dialogbereit nach moskau das war auch
ihre zentrale nachricht über die ukraine
krise müsse wieder verhandelt werden in
etablierten kreis
jetzt ist es aus unserer sicht wichtig
den normandie prozess wieder mit leben
zu füllen um endlich bei der
implementierung der minsker vereinbarung
voranzukommen
kiew moskau berlin und paris an einem
tisch begeisterungsstürme gab es für
diese idee nicht heute in moskau aber
auch keine deutliche absage
länger gesprochen als geplant und
christian sum in moskau lässt sich
darauf aufbauen
ich würde sagen ja man konnte bei dem
gespräch heute jetzt zwar nicht davon
ausgehen dass es in der ukraine frage da
einen durchbruch geben wird aber es war
ein antrittsbesuch wo die beiden sich
beschnuppert haben sich gegenseitig den
puls gefühlt haben sich zugehört haben
und annalena baerbock ist auf offener
bühne auch zumindest nicht bloßgestellt
worden dass es anderen politikerinnen
und politikern hier schon passiert es
soll auch weiter gespräche geben morgen
wird us-außenminister blinken in kiew
sein und danach direkt weiter nach
berlin reisen und am freitag sollen sich
sergei lavrov der russische
aussenminister und us-außenminister
blinken in genf treffen also das zeigt
alle seiten wollen irgendwie noch weiter
im gespräch sein und miteinander
verhandeln um irgendwie vielleicht doch
eine lösung in dieser krise zu finden
schön dann christian nach moskau ja zur
ukraine krise heute auch ein treffen
zwischen kanzler scholz und
nato-generalsekretär
stoltenberg auf nord stream zwei als
mögliches druckmittel auf russland
angesprochen sagte scholz das alles zu
diskutieren sei bislang hatte er die
gaspipeline ein privatwirtschaftliches
projekt genannt zu den corona zahlen
jetzt das robert-koch-institut hat 74
1405 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
registriert das sind 28 1715 mehr als
vor einer woche
193 todesfälle kamen hinzu bei der 7
tage incidents wieder ein neuer
höchstwert er liegt jetzt bei 5
153,2
in der landwirtschaft braucht einen
aufbruch das haben zwei ministerien der
neuen regierung heute gemeinsam
gefordert in berlin skizzierten
umweltministerin lemke und
landwirtschaftsminister erste mir ihre
pläne die zeit sei reif
landwirtschaft natur- umwelt- und
klimaschutz endlich unter einem hut zu
bekommen erklärte özdemir beide
ministerien wollen sich etwa für weniger
pestizide einsetzen und dafür dass eu
fördergelder nicht mehr nur nach
betriebsgröße fließen
das europäische parlament hat eine neue
präsidentin die malteser in roberta mit
solar ist erst die dritte frau und mit
43 jahren die bislang jüngste im amt die
politikerin der konservativen svp
fraktion setzte sich gleich im ersten
wahlgang mit deutlicher mehrheit durch
vor 80 jahren in einer villa in berlin
hochrangige vertreter des ns regimes
treffen sich um über die sogenannte
endlösung der judenfrage zu beraten das
treffen ging als wannsee konferenz in
die geschichte ein bei einem besuch
heute bekräftigt der bundespräsident
steinmeier es dürfe nicht vergessen
werden dass hier vor 80 jahren ein
staatsapparat den völkermord an den
jüdinnen und juden europas plante
henriette de maizière und stefanie groß
berichten die
villa am wannsee ort der täter
1942 lädt reinhard heydrich es über
gruppenführer 14 spitzenbeamte des
reiches ein sie organisieren die massen
vernichtung der europäischen juden kalt
bürokratisch eine dauerausstellung
erinnert an den horror besuch des
bundespräsidenten mit seiner frau
dass ich gleich es nicht wiederholt das
ist die absicht jeder erinnerung an die
verbrechen des ns staates in unserem
staat in unserem demokratischen staat
trägt jeder einzelne verantwortung
auch beamte und beamtinnen einer
hierarchisch organisierten verwaltung
die rede hielt der bundespräsident bei
der premiere des zdf spielfilms die
wannseekonferenz der film beschreibt
nüchtern die planung des grauens etwa
die gaskammern für unsere eigenen männer
beschränkt sich die tätigkeit im grunde
auf das sicherstellen geordnete abläufe
sowie das freisetzen der nötigen gas
aber der anblick dieser vielen toten der
transport zu den höfen wird erfolgen
durch arbeits juden die wiederum
schlussendlich ebenfalls sonderbar
werden elegant beim spielfilm haben wir
uns immer wieder die frage gestellt wie
kann man eine konferenz von 15
verantwortungsträgern in kalten
technokraten deutsche darstellen die
über was ganz ungeheuerliches reden ich
glaube es ist gelungen die
wannseekonferenz seiner schüchternen
blick in die geschichte das erinnern
wichtig für die zukunft
ja das war es von uns wir sehen uns
morgen um 19 uhr wieder um kurz nach 10
gibt es das heute journal und gleich
nach dem wetter geht's wieder fix rüber
zur handball em nach bratislava
[Musik]
genannt heute nacht ist es meist bedeckt
es bildet sich auch wieder nebel bei
temperaturen von plus 3 bis minus 8 grad
und auch morgen ist es erst wieder
lieblich zum teil aber auch sonne ich
hier in der südosthälfte von nordwesten
kommen neue regenwolken heran und in den
westlichen mittelgebirgen kann es schon
mittags für schneeregen reichen
temperaturen von ein bis sieben grad
spannend wird dann die nacht auf
donnerstag wenn es nämlich nicht mehr
nur in den mittelgebirgen sondern auch
im flachland schneit und so kann es dann
am donnerstag ganz gefährlich werden mit
ungemütliche winterwetter mit
glättegefahr
und auch am freitag liegen die
temperatur bei minus zwei bis plus
sieben grad mehr schnee fällt dann am
samstag genannt